[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
what is up everyone let me know how
everything sounds how's it going
happy Monday and welcome to GameSpot
live uh if you did not catch last week
stream then you might not have noticed
but I am on work from home mandatory as
is the rest of the GameSpot office they
want to make sure everyone stays safe
during this time and we hope you guys
are staying safe too so if things look a
little different that's why everybody's
on work from home so that means we still
want to bring you our content and we
still want to bring you our daily live
streams so yeah the streams are from
home too so now first things first as
you guys know back in the office we
always have two people or we have a
co-host
so Furtick games like this I would
usually bring in someone who would be
much better at beauty at these types of
games these souls light games but that
means you guys just have to put up with
my gameplay today prism neo 2 I did play
some of the neo 1 and like the first one
and then they did have the demo out for
this one
and I tried the demo I was getting
destroyed so let's just see how this
goes
but yeah what's up guys thanks for
joining things stopping by happy Monday
side work man good to see a Brandon is
back nice yeah we were having a little
bit of technical difficulties there but
the fine folks over at GameSpot's made
it happen
alright so let's give this go I'm I feel
like we'll we'll be okay I've heard
through the grapevine it's not as
difficult as the first one but we'll see
let me know the volume levels and if
everything sounds good for you guys
upon a time a giant
it's appeared in a distant village
terrifying
villages welcomed him with joy believing
he brought blessings
by the villages he began to attack
villagers decided to make a stand
cool sort of golden stairs
forging them into a blade volumes good
nice alright so we're gonna go
I can suffer without having to deal with
the technical side
the young
trust
oh that uh that didn't sound too good
you know I just just off me I don't want
to see that Marty yeah just yeah if I
was that person definitely just off me
at that point
oh wait that wasn't even her Oh
well then I just can't wait to see how
our child turns out all I know is that
there will be no limit to their
potential
oh yeah there was a pretty in-depth
character creation now I'm the type of
person where I would definitely spend my
whole life creating a character but for
the sake of time I don't want to do this
oh that's so sweet
that's really sweet
this one's adorable yeah yeah all right
I'm just gonna keep it quick I feel like
that's fine
I trust whatever else is and oh okay I
have to pick between these now these
look so cool this is kind of sweet it's
like your parents talking about you ooh
that one looks cool too
Wow they all look cool okay I'm sure
there's some people in here who have
already been playing what is this uh
just cosmetic right now or will this
make a big difference from you later
they all look really cool I'm not gonna
lie the phantom one looks pretty bright
I think I'm gonna go with the Phantom
one actually everything sounded good
nice all right
thank goodness everything in my being
wants me to oh wait I get all three of
these they just want me to pick what it
looks like when it's out is what it is
right too many choices
I spent a huge part of the demo messing
with my character I like this one all
right no more no more before I get lost
in in all the nonsense no more I will
yeah exactly raid I will spend way too
much time to be Bob Jones I could easily
turn it into a character creation stream
only but all right it's cosmetic only
all right thanks Jeremy
I was nervous for a second never asked
to make big decisions like that takes me
a while already right this is looking
like the
the demo a little bit so maybe I'll just
be a
gotta go fast but my stamina see I spent
a lot of time hanging around this area
in the demo2 picking which sword I
should use all right help me out guys
help me out man I wish I could get like
Jordan or Tim and a voice chat right now
and just be like help share all your
wisdom with me hmm
strength sounds like it would be would
be good yeah I'll go back later when I'm
off stream and spend a few hours in
character creation so let's see
okay
and then I get to pick two so if I think
this one maybe I should pick Lika a
quicker one our one down
yeah
okay spear spear is the best all right
let's see instead of what though I feel
like I need to have at least one kind of
fast attack weapon or can I just uh
charge all of them and just pocum's just
poke them all in the eye
am I reading here oh wait wait wait I
don't want to go yet I want to make sure
we've got the goods
so the spear and the sword these are
these two the money right here is the
money oh wait I dropped one I gotta go
pick up where'd my other one go
oh there it is yeah yeah okay cool yes a
weapon that is larger than you is a
great choice I agree all right well
let's do this guy's I feel like I'm
gonna have to be very meticulous with my
spacing and all that jazz with these two
weapons but hey this is this is what you
guys recommend we will do we will
survive let's do it oh hello whoo I feel
powerful or the bird or magic well this
is the Phantom one yeah that one is
really cool how much magic am I gonna be
using just like the way that form looks
a lot
okay guardian spirits go
go back did I pick two with the other
one go oh there it is
yeah I kind of like this one
[Music]
it's so powerful because I'm floating
all the powerful people float just
saying alright let's go forward I wish
to leave this place
alright let's let's pray
the man who achieved no small trap and
bringing unity to this nation was poor
it was born in a poor village in a time
of civil strife but was blessed with a
shrewd mind and the creators of it
someone needs help
we're here
[Music]
oh dang slice them man this looks really
good actually float and spear my enemies
yes that that's what's about to happen
right now that guy is my sure
you can read of repulsive vibes from her
demon forum yeah I feel that it's like a
mix of the colors and like that scribe
flicking thing I think all right I
acquired a divine branch fragment if you
use one during a mission you can quit
the mission and return to the map
however you will lose all the Amrita
currently in your possession all right
well let's begin the first one shall we
right so where does he want off or not
well I guess we helped him and he's just
he's moving on to be afraid but safe
I just want to find all the kodamas yay
they're so cute hi let's pray let us
pray let those little guys alright wait
could I level something up already it's
on exclamation points we're gonna
upgrade your stats you'll go to see
updated stats in the riot okey-dokey
gotcha right so I need 300 until the
next level is that one
all right let's let's go
taking a look around
[Music]
tradeable it's always so ominous in the
beginning oh yeah they're prepping me to
start attacking
oh boy oh really why are you so fast all
right quiet
hey I didn't die to the first minion
that's that's a good that's good for me
cuz in the demo I definitely died to the
first guy I ran into it was a is a human
and not like a little gremlin but still
[Laughter]
you only need to 58 you have oh it said
50 was when I got what's gonna have
leftover okay I'll go back William go
back cuz I need all the power I can get
oh I forgot when I go here the enemies
come back I definitely have enough now
alright so yeah man okay I'll start with
that one I think one of the weapons I
have already is leveling that one up
is he over here again yeah yes I forgot
spear will own all I'm trusting you
right here I believe in you
oh man app stop it please stay over
there alright so far as spheres working
out uh hopefully it works out it gets
this guy oh man am I really supposed to
take this thing on right now because
yeah
all right let's assess the situation I
have some cover here
okay.you sees me now how much can i oh
my goodness oh boy oh boy alright
Oh ki dokie we can oh man
no he's terrifying no real ill
ring-around-the-rosie action here buddy
oh oh my goodness oh I wasn't ready for
this I could tell you that right now
oh he's angry oh man okay
ding I most definitely was not ready for
that
no run past alright you got it
you don't got to tell me like oh yeah
that is definitely a big ol nope yeah
you can stay over there buddy and don't
mind me we're out of here
[Laughter]
he was angry he's very angry no don't
look at me don't look at me
ah Kodama hello me let me raid this
guy's pockets face jay said I have this
gaming it's hard I can't even beat the
dark horse monster at the end of the
first level I'm I'm already scared
because this guy had me super shook and
I can handle these guys
Oh
ah dang no okay
chop-chop this little head off no it's
all good I will try my best I have this
spear spoilers I mean if this is the
right level I'm sure we'll get to it at
some point and lee-sia have an idea
what's at wall stop it
don't don't Ram it like that
strong oh I'm trying to knock a monster
first 8-bit use item shortcuts I hear
noise someone someone creeping on me
over there alright yeah alright oh I
have two pages of shortcuts
wait I'm miss the prompt already got
some stuff wait
I have 99 stones or it oh oh wait that's
I don't know what those numbers on the
outside mean this is spirit better
looks the same
skill customization oh here we go
triangle high stance oh I forgot there's
different stances man there's a lot of
stuff in this game
hmm
it's a lot of stuff left to learn
obviously we just started tutorials
we're good on that alright alright let's
continue max you can carry okay that's
what I was wondering at first
[Music]
our to encircle berries varies based on
guardian spirit currently and use the
phantom burst Connor transforms you into
it you okay temporarily and then readies
a weapon to guard against an incoming
attack guarding at just the right moment
to block an enemy's burst attack will
stagger the enemy and inflict a
substantial amount of key damage
play the movie heck yeah noise noted
let's block again okay l1 but there are
certain attacks I can block right
I can also carry in this too
have the attacks in different stances
all right got it
how do I change stance again there we go
sorry I had to remember real quick how
to switch the way just like an two
stances real quick oh man I bet you the
combos are really fun in there are their
really cool combos in this oops oh yeah
it's like active reload type stuff sorry
I'm still yeah no kidding oh hey you
scared me
the jump-scares
alright there's another one right there
okay
um I don't think I want to fight this
guy yet
all right this thing brings out scary
dudes that I don't want to deal with
just yet so let's keep moving
see ya later Squidward thanks for tuning
in
all right here's where I start getting
lost sometimes I have to walk through
this huh
I was I was a little worried you
investment combos more experience you
get with weapons as you get through the
game you know mechanics become easier to
understand all right
what old wait oh I was too close to it
can I beat this guy whoa whoa hold up Oh
hold up a second
[Music]
well good thing I killed those guys
earlier is he just gonna stay out the
entire time now whoa it was too close to
him Wow
oh man there is there are some stones at
him yo it up Akash welcome back uh you
didn't miss much I'm just over here is
struggling is that person on the floor
oh I came from this way I think oh my
god no I didn't go this way yeah I did
yeah I didn't think I did oh alright
mini-boss time I I can't run from this
one I have to actually fight him I'm
struggling already though alright let me
think about this wait hold on
maybe I should try to equip some items
or make sure my do I have all the best
stuff right when they hold on to the
spear but this one looks better yeah I
definitely want some armor oh cool
my character is so sick alright it's the
little things
speed up key recovery I mean I don't
have much
don't think that's gonna do me any good
right there whoo this game is like very
fun I mean I'm having a good time so far
but I also like horror games and I think
just of like fear right now me like
having to face these bosses probably
what's making it funny for me all right
let me heal up here
did you see the way that guy was
twirling though I'm just saying he's
he's a big guy he's a big boss right
there and the fact that he was spinning
around like that maybe use a faster
weapon yeah I agree
yeah let me uh I think I had a couple of
think I huh there's some hatchets
it's probably yeah I'll go with the
hatchets alright ah
alright camel I'm about to I'm gonna do
it I'm gonna do it
I just gotta build up the courage oh
that didn't start off very well all
right let me see I'm far away
okay are to encircle at the oh I
definitely hit our one in circle like it
like a dummy alright it's okay you know
when I wanted to start with um full life
anyways Oh dig are good all the way back
this wasn't here before these weren't
here before
oh man can they get through here
oh I didn't open it from the other side
awesome alright you know what next time
I'll just have no fear whoa Wow why does
that hurt so much dang it a rare
that hurt that hurt oh no eh I need to
do there we go
kind of Miss my spear already I'm gonna
fight that guy again I just want to get
my health up real quick oh yeah I
brought one of the little go down this
back
no I can't let him do that can't can't
let you buddy
all right I got a run by this guy again
oh girl these dead bodies here and see
I'm not the only one right some fear is
good though I agree Craven that's what
that's what makes this fun for me
whereas like if games like like God of
War it was fun in a different way God of
War was fun in a way where I was like I
felt invincible so I would just tear
everything up this is fun in a way where
I'm not invincible and is actually a
little mindful here I gotta put my
fighting game fundamentals to play which
are clearly not very good so was this
that wasn't the door I need to go this
way
oh yeah oh no I hate you come on oh
lordy Lordy
alright let me open this for later cuz
I'm gonna need it actually I can go heal
now then I opened it fight that guy
again I don't want to waste any of my
heels yet oh I can I can summon them to
help me oh okay okay I see it
I couldn't do it right there for some
reason I'm not sure I'm really liking
this uh this saw right even though it's
kind of our whole I guess I'll bring the
spirit back through the spear and the
hatchets for now Dwayne likes
challenging games so he loves this noise
yeah see oh wait I what oh my god he's
too good he's too good no well this
stance what stance am i an interesting
that one was
dang how you hit me with that to hit
combo so far wait sneak attack
yokai if I'm sneaky enough this
character kinda looks like the hair it's
the long hair I wish had one of those
hats though alright this guy got me last
time he hit me one good time No stop it
okay
low stance yeah she was she was whipping
it that time oh hi
man those I gotta go clear those other
two little ones before I fight this guy
also because oh there's my there's my
fish I'm gonna go pick em up real quick
then I want to get rid of these little
guys cuz when I'm running away from this
guy later see you straight oh no I
forgot see no no no I forgot they eat
each other oh my goodness
Oh No get out of there crap why did I
have to forget about that because now
I'm really scared oh my goodness you
know what I deserved a dime for that
sheesh he ate him so fast oh man they're
like you need all the help you can get
okay oh no and I can't swim man is a
struggle living in this world yes
mistakes were definitely made Bob Jones
that is true let's try and not to fall
into the water in which we cannot swim
oh I was scared she was gonna take one
more leap into death I'm drying no all
right so when I go to these other guys
we're I have to get this other one first
through the house so I don't wake up the
one over there
but I don't want to go near that right
there
please follow
all right still have a good amount of
live left now the real in the real
battle let me switch to my axes and
think about my life for a second oh it
was my um spirit animal over here no
she's just Enzo
alright let's go
Oh pray for me men ate it rings gonna
come out swirling and Turrell in arts
two and a circle at the same time okay
oh my goodness
okay and so yeah let's have them calm
down I'm gonna have to go for take three
alright so aren't feel encircled if
that's my parry right so I can just
attack immediately after that in theory
all right I guess let's do this again
hey buddy
oh my goodness okay
very nimble
[Music]
Oh
oh I tried I tried to do the little
Perry okay so I should just parried and
then dash away that seems like a better
a better option dang it
gotta kill all these little ones on the
way over there right I can do this I can
do this
actually I go like the low stance
against these little guys right here for
this hey-hey here we go here we go
I think there is a Samurai Jack game
coming out Shem Shamari sorry I probably
pronounced that wrong
[Music]
hmm there's my fish get my fishes to try
and they did last time
wake this guy up and bring him in here
what Wow okay um so Maddie hit me I'm
like trying to conserve every bit of
life I can oh I got it into it
way to go ah all right I can't swim
I can't fall down there that's for sure
ah all right so let's heal up just take
a deep breath and that axe is the wave
okay
let's do this
psiphon can top and katana are your
favorite acts as the third ooh
interesting
okay
no no no oh man this guy
[Music]
No
yeah I like that I like that Perry and
then dodge no oh my god he has so much
life Oh totally mistimed all of that oh
my god and I tried to get inside just
you know that was my own fault this is I
feel like I'm learning a fighting game
right now I gotta learn my parry timings
my stance cancels all right let's try to
breathe through this
because now I'm gaining confidence
against that guy I just got it
I just gotta time it right my parry it
actually has a pretty long window though
so I'm just being too scared and doing
it like the second I start to panic crap
maybe she
boy this might be bad
I need to kill him right now okay my
stamina
okay let's see I need to get past this
guy
I can do this I got my parody which is
that right there I got this I got this I
got this
let's go key pulses hit our one on I you
stamina yeah you right you're right Oh
oh I missed that I missed it I can do
this
wow he's read rounds gonna go missed it
again oh that looks so fortunate don't
actually need it my gosh
oh crap yeah tack twice first counter
and then Dutch yeah I'm trying to use it
as a starter and it's clearly not
working
I missed it again
you can at least practice on these
little guys before I get to the main
boss
I have a pretty lenient window there
just a little bit more lenient than I
thought
[Music]
oh he's still alive no no I can't leave
him alive
all right now the actual problem
don't pee with our tune told read attack
okay let's see
Bram I'm feeling more confident here oh
that was an accident didn't wanna do
that oh man he gets me every time when I
try to do that
[Music]
uh-huh
[Music]
okay
oh my brain tend to goo right there when
I was trying to get away I don't like
being like next to the wall and they're
so would the old monster life is all
right
Kemp can't panic like this
I'll miss that one
all right as long as I don't go over
there where those other little guys are
they shouldn't be an issue so I'm just
gonna take out my dude well I just
wanted to pick up a dude oh okay
why do I keep trying to dodge with
square it's so annoying
Oh
Oh
[Music]
oh my god it was like Splash Damage
there the music it's like rubbing salt
moon and then they're like hey in case
you didn't get it the first ten times we
taught you this move yes this again Oh
My lordy oh hey I've skill points that's
how many times I would do this one I
have all these skill points I have skill
point now two skill points ooh
that's that's a good one mitts dance at
the end of a combo okay cool
yeah I like that one learn that one I
have one more yeah all right these sound
like these might be useful I know I am
getting wrecked by this guy it's true
it's true
and I play a lot of Kingdom Hearts and
like block like guard and dodges squares
so I'm like I'm in the vortex or you
know straight up straight up
and actually what I need to do right now
if I'm gonna use the axes against this
guy I need to use them here because I
noticed so keep the key pulse after ribs
is different so let me see
III
wait actually I just leveled up some
stuff with my spear yeah I just got that
I just got those skills of my spear well
it's better for this this the spear or
the axis the axis looked good because it
looks like they were more damaged
are they really stronger yeah you know
what let's just stick with the game plan
it almost got us there keep my helpful
yeah I have to not forget about that
let's let's do this
Oh No if I get hit I know
[Music]
I uh I was mentally defeated on that one
oh dang
No
crap oh I forgot I can't get get out of
there girl can't get my stamina back
there all right that wasn't the greatest
story but I need
okay
yeah that's it like no damage so
oh yeah that was knocking dude through
early again oh my god what am i
panicking and just I do it right away
it's just cuz he's scary and he's
looking at me in the face
dang this is tough I'm not gonna lie
stuff for me you guys probably breeze
through this oh ok I guess I like like
midstance better with these ones so far
like low stance where with the spear so
far oh it's old life what
Oh cuz yeah he was on the ground submit
stance makes sense makes sense
oh boy alright can we and do this don't
panic it's get out oh no
I didn't do a great time no don't
[Music]
I wasn't close enough oh this guy was
destroying me whoever was talking about
some in level boss they couldn't be I
can't even get to that guy right now all
right
square is not dodge Lordy there we go
yeah what up ween
Oh triangle triangle yeah there we go
there we go all right don't panic don't
dodge the square definitely did it no
the fact that's like going through the
wall all right
I'm I'm getting impatient I'm getting so
impatient right now that's because it's
destroying me so not getting patient
alright I'm gonna get this dis guy it's
the last thing I do on this stream
okay it's gonna have a little temper
tantrum
[Music]
okay
oh you use high stance re ah me try high
stance this time because I mean I was
definitely getting in the groove there
but dang I felt good about that one too
it looks like I'm finally learning the
pattern I was what die baby I thought
yeah I was feeling good that one oh I
can destroy his horn with a hi Stan
hmm I shall try it I am a bit reckless
that is true let's let's see here
no no oh oh dodge girl dodge
too early again when it actually does
hit it does a big chunk of damage so
every time I missed that is is very bad
for my life oh all these all these
people who want to help me also died
here
[Applause]
Wow of course of course he got one good
hit that did like half my life so messed
up alright don't waste perfectly good
heels not that I live long enough to use
them right now anyways damn
[Music]
Oh
wallets there's no way too soon
no why why is it ah Thank You Jacob for
believing in me I need I need all this
afraid Gary now I really can't beat this
guy
oh I don't I kind of felt like I was
having better success in like hey I'm
practicing oh oh I hate you so much I
hate you so much right now
why all right
uh yeah you know what Victor I feel like
I just did that on accident and I was
like hmm
that was cool that that word hey I was
doing
okay it's try to read these patterns
here my god
I thought that was that was gonna work
right there I definitely do not want to
be in that corner in any corner
whatsoever oh my goodness
I should summon someone to help me out I
can't oh I need to buy some stuff around
let's get some assistance wait that's
right I can buy stuff from here oh I
want a blessing IRL because I need it
where do I get these cups from oh wait
no go back what what
who
all right you know what I don't need to
summon anybody
if I dodge can I not get the key pulse
just a question it's like I would did
like combo and I dodge and I tried to
keep pulse but it either went away
before I could or I couldn't do it not
sure
okay game face on
we freakin got this alright get my fish
out of this corner never again will we
be in that corner alright let's go
nope shoot
[Music]
this is that Wow there we go
[Music]
No and my fish is like right on his body
so I try go back for it later like
dodging will cancel thank you folks yeah
ding
I've been ruined by like so many other
games like I play so much like I played
all the Arkham games and like the spider
a game like Kingdom Hearts and man you
never realized how much those games hold
your hand and so you play something like
this alright let's do this come on I
cannot go down like this
god of course so dumb I'm so dumb my
stamina my character always like soda
when like I waste all my stamina I'm
trying to attack and she's just like who
alright game face on I'm gonna try to
get my fishing rod yeah
all right let's see Manny started off
with that one
he's really gonna chase me all the way
over here oh I can't go over here
actually shoot I I did this to myself Oh
No okay
that me that was scary alright reset I
forgot I didn't kill those little guys
over there so I think what's up dude
oh I didn't get the other one I
cancelled my key again
dad
oh okay okay okay I'm alive I'm alive
[Music]
shoot
two hits you said two hits and I'm doing
all three I'm doing all three and I
shouldn't be doing there should we do -
yeah it's yeah you know what just gonna
hold that it's gonna hold that I bought
give me a little bit better at it every
time but I'm trying to practice the two
hit and then whatever on that guy but no
he just wanted lay down
all right Jesus please take the wheel
[Music]
hi
[Music]
ah that didn't even hit me realistically
he kind of just hit me like what's chest
[Music]
but whatever I'll hold that oh I wasn't
paying attention he's trying to read the
chat little buddy straight up about to
die and I'm not wasting one of my health
things I'm just gonna read the chat
before I run over there which might be
helpful Oh actually I think I got I'm in
the wrong place I've learned some skills
with my hatchets charge your attack and
throw both of your hatchets 100 that
might be a good one
charge up my blade I might not have the
time for that all right let's just wait
well we can either need a level this one
up first form a low spinning attack with
both hatchets aimed at the enemies feet
well this boss needs something high up
brain so I should probably go for
something in high stance
that one looks cool but I feel like this
monster's gonna just punch me right out
of that oh man I forgot about my demon
form actually all right you know what
let's just move it
[Music]
all right can be greedy right now
now is greedy I just said it in it
[Music]
okay
okay
no no okay
he's off cos to death
oh Jesus
I feel like they lower the his
difficulty that run because they were
like you know what you died the maximum
amount of times yeah let me take your
soul core feel so good
to take your soul core we did it
I panicked there when I missed missed
I'm that first let me let me drink some
heels let me let me put on some better
equipment
let me feel myself through because I
know you guys wish we had a better
player on right now but I feel damn good
that I just beat that guy and I don't
care who knows it
first samurai hell it's like lower than
this one but it looks cool let me put on
some good armor and we put on you know
all of this yes thank you guys oh you
guys are the best you're so supportive
thank you so much holy [ __ ] excuse my
link whoa what did I just think on my
pants nah but those fans back on girl
alright Maya quits you know I kind of
just want the whole the whole set but
this hat this hat is too cool now I'm
leaving the Hat the Hat the Hat wins all
right I already have this one oh yeah
Brandon's like haha ended on that note
but we literally only have six minutes
left of the stream and I low-key do you
want to do that but I will play out the
rest of the stream time as promised I'm
so sorry that it took me so long oh man
yeah
not me
oh I have another guy here yeah
why don't those guys to attack the other
samurais down there now find a shortcut
oh to get back right all right yeah why
don't they attack those guys this
that's messed up yeah exactly
that type of game with those fans back
on our yeah shortcut no they're coming
back
very low I could take them Oh famous
last words
no if I died of these little goobers
after that guy I just fought it's about
to happen
oh my gosh Wow oh I'm stuck oh no oh no
that's definitely not what we wanted
that's what's up can you go somewhere
else so he's still chasing me oh yeah
get out of here you know what before I
die to you this stupid guy I think we
need to go ahead and I mean we have
three minutes left of the stream
honestly I would not have beaten that
guy without you without all of y'all's
help yeah go back go back home go back
home
all right yes fees
oh good thing that guy didn't wake up I
feel like my shortcut is over there let
me just get this shortcut race now it's
not over that's fine all right you guys
this was really fun actually getting
destroyed like that is always a humble
reminder that you know there's a lot of
different styles of games out there to
learn um I hope you guys enjoyed the
stream even though yeah it is what it is
don't forget every single weekday at
2:00 p.m. Pacific time you can tune in
to GameSpot live we are indeed on
company while a company-wide mandatory
work from home so all the game spotlight
daily streams are gonna be from home as
well I'll be holding it down and then of
course for community Fridays John Luke
and Ben will still be holding it down
from their homes so we still hope you
guys tune in and don't forget to tune in
to the youtube channel and the website
because we still have content going up
every single day there's a lot of
awesome games coming out this week alone
and beyond that we're still making
content for us so make sure you're
tuning in and following along and thank
you guys so much for your help and your
energy to get me past that mini bus
wasn't even a bus sweet Jesus hopefully
next time we can get the souls pros that
we have in the office on stream for you
guys but I really really appreciate
playing and I had a lot of fun anyways
and I hope you guys did too so thank you
so much have a good day and I will catch
you guys mañana
you